nochmals luca und meine lieben freunde
ihr wisst dass ich ein ziemlich großer
spaß bin und das bin ich mittlerweile
seit 23 jahren denn ich bin am 21
februar 1996 geboren und ich habe mich
heute einfach mal gefragt was ist
eigentlich noch so an meinem geburtstag
passiert und da wird herzlich willkommen
hier heute meine damen und herren zu
diesem neuen video auf seinem kanal wir
befinden uns gerade auf dieser website
hier die heißt my birthday ninja und ihr
seht schon february 26
ich glaube nicht cooler typ geworden
verriet jolie verriet 96 birthday facts
also diese website jetzt einige fakten
bei dinge die auch am 21 februar 1996
passiert sind was wir allerdings im
laufe des videos ja auch noch machen
werden ist dass wir uns eine tagesschau
episode vom 21.02 1996 anschauen werden
also eine nachrichtensendung von vor 23
jahren
aber wir schauen jetzt mal was diese
webseite hier so sagt im ferrari tief
verschneiten 96 moslems playoffs trifft
die second day of the year
ich bin am 52
tag des jahres geboren und starb meine
days until next birthday der aaron
henrichs xv days left 4 dead space day
also an alle die das er gerade sehen
noch 164 tage zeit um eine reise zum
mond zu schenken
dort gilt dort motorcycle and area brit
award the same day you that they will be
one heart with dog day
ich bin schon ein alter runter
allerdings würde ich sagen verlassen
jetzt die website birthday ninja und
gehen auf die website geburtstags
rechner denn hier gibt es noch ein paar
mehr fakten und zwar gerne die website
mir ganz genau sagen wie alt ich bin 23
jahre sechs monate 18 tage 16 stunden
und 20 minuten 6 2 sekunden
wie alt seid ihr eigentlich schreibt mir
das gerne in die kommentare das wird
nicht mehr interessieren der 21 2 1996
war ein mittwoch ja genau das wissen wir
schon
der mittwoch ist der tag des odin
das jahr 1996 war ein schaltjahr weniger
spannend für alle die nicht am 29
februar geboren sind das nächste jahr
mein gott ich war acht tage später
geworden
da wäre ich jetzt erst vier oder fünf
oder so summarum liegt aber im endeffekt
niemand wird sagen wir gehen jetzt mal
weg von dem ganzen lesen fakten krams
über meinen geburtstag und hinzu
tagesschau hier ist das erste deutsche
fernsehen mit der tagesschau
hey was für ein altes ins co
guten abend meine damen abend nach
wochenlangen erfolglosen verhandlungen
statt der schwer angeschlagene bremer
vulkan verbundenen den letzten
rettungsversuch okay also der bremer
vulkan verbund wusste dass es vulkane in
bremen gibt der bremer vulkan verbund
ist also auf dem weg dahin pleite zu
werden es blöd sein dass er auch alles
einfach ablief von seinem zettel darin
vulkan beschäftigten wurde angesichts
der probleme keine übermäßige hoffnung
gemacht okay ich finde es wirklich irre
dass er die ganze zeit sitzt und von
seinem zettel abliest heutzutage sind
die tagesschau moderatorin so voll in
ihrem film drin und wissen das alles und
gucken sie die ganze zeit in die kamera
und ah ja mehr und viele prompt beim
bildschirm keine ahnung ging beim vulkan
die lichter aus ist bremen nord raus
beim bremer vulkane krams gegen die
lichter aus und beim land gingen die
lichter an einer puppe ein wachstum eine
halbe million mehr arbeitslose und um
export steigerungsraten erst gegen
jahresende könnte es danach zu einem
aufwärtstrend com scheiße ich bin
geboren und direkt die arbeitslosenzahl
in höhe rund ein drittel aller betriebe
will stellen streichen
500.000 arbeitsplätze könnten verloren
gehen
also irgendwas tolles an meinem
geburtstag was ihr beim politischen
aschermittwoch in bayern sind die
parteien wieder traditionelle hat
miteinander ins gericht gegangen ich
fände das zum kotzen und eine solche
regierung hört winkel
[Musik]
waren glatte tag der 21 12 1996 an der
küste von wales beginnt mit einsätzen im
hochwasser zur stunde ein neuer versuch
den leckgeschlagenen bild tanker sea
empress freizuschleppen achtung kaka
gefahr wird immer größer dass der super
tanker auseinanderbricht achtung grüne
neue jetzt wird es dramatisch
ja dies ist vielleicht der letzte
versuch ganz ganz große katastrophe zu
verhindern
ach du scheiße jetzt auch noch von öl
tanker gekentert
an meinem geburtstag das loch im
berliner haushalt ist größer als bisher
angenommen
geil finanzsenatorin fugmann heesing
dafür betrag bis 1999 über 30 milliarden
mark ach sie milliarden mehr als
zunächst geschätzt
zudem haben wir noch 7 milliarden d-mark
mehr schulden als geschätzt wurde also
geil echt ein polster februar der tag
sollte in die geschichtsbücher eingehen
als der beste tag des landes vielleicht
kann ja wenigstens das wetter noch
irgendetwas positives raus reifen der
wind kommt morgen aus dem nordwesten an
der ostseeküste weht frisch sonst mäßig
ok positive nachricht vom 12 februar 92
96 der wind ist mäßig aber jedes
unternehmen ist pleite gegangen sind 7
milliarden euro - und gegen welche
parteien streiten sich und irgendwer ist
gestorben und dem öltank von der küste
weg
ich
irgendwie unheil über diese welt
gebracht an anderer stelle mich dass
heute gehen jetzt alles aber endet meine
lieben freunde ich habe mich einfach mal
gefragt hey was ist eigentlich am helm
geburtstag so passiert und anscheinend
nur scheiße allerdings trotzdem
interessiert und ich wollte mir das
zusammen mit euch mal anschauen wenn es
euch dementsprechend gefallen hat das
heutige wieder das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier darin schreibt
normalen in die kommentare waren ihr
geburtstag habt also wie alt seid ihr
das würde mich echt mal interessieren
ihr könnt definitiv auch auf dieser
website von ard euch dann eure
tagesschau anschauen oder euren
geburtstag einfach mal googlen fans auf
jeden fall wirklich recht interessant
abonniert main kanal falls doch kein
demokrat und falls sie abonnent würde
ich mich selber ein dings freuen wenn
ihr darauf klickt das ist so eine glocke
dies unter dem video dann bekommt
demnach richtigen wenn ich das hochladen
ja super gau okay gut ich geh jetzt
packen
[Musik]